let's uh let's uh do a little myth
busting
starting off with the big one the
elephant in the room could it be
yeah what what could this question
possibly be
where do you get your protein matt your
runner
robert you're a power strength athlete
where do you get your protein
i mean we've given the same answer for
the years and that you don't need that
much
which i know is so unsatisfying to
people i think they just
want the secret source so that we can
get on how to do it but
uh i mean i just don't think about even
even recently i've gotten into
kettlebell lifting like i'm much more
these days
that than a runner uh after kind of a
prolonged just like
you know lack of inspiration in sports
and just kind of doing the
parenting thing instead and
entrepreneurship and all that but like
i'm kind of back now and really feeling
great and having great results and
i don't i don't i don't take protein
powder i eat
beans fairly often i eat seitan now and
then
i eat tofu which is beans but it's it's
if you eat whole foods
it's there i mean and the recent athlete
studies her saying
especially for for vegetarian or vegan
athletes who don't you don't and
we can come out and say it you don't
absorb plant protein i think
about 10 lower sorry you get a 10 less
sort of efficiency in absorption so you
need a little bit more for sure
but it's not a ton more and like three
quarters of a gram per pound of body
weight
that that would be plenty uh you know
and and the
the regular non-athlete recommendation
is much lower than that it's something
like 0.36 per gram per
per grams per pound per day uh really
not that much and i think i think most
people are eating way too much protein
which i know we all say that and
people don't seem to believe it but uh
and i think that's why the question
perpetuates because there is no great
answer like oh yeah this is this is all
you need to do to get that
huge amount but you just don't need that
much
yeah i think it's almost a a separate
episode i mean
this this topic could just go on forever
but i think it starts with
why do you believe that you need a whole
lot of protein and what is your
understanding of protein and what it
does
and why are you obsessed with it i think
it's for everyone to answer
why do we try to optimize our protein
intake without optimizing our
carbohydrate intake or optimizing our
fat intake or optimizing our sleep
or or optimizing our recovery or
optimizing these other
areas of performance that are our
hydration we don't we focus on protein i
think it's been
the most brilliantly marketed thing
around
because what it's done is it's convinced
people who are not active non-athletes
it's convinced them that they need to
reach for protein
uh in in you know enriched food
as a beverage when they're sitting on
the couch and watching television
if they're going to reach for something
it's got to be protein infused whether
that's a meat product or a beverage
or a protein water or anything else
because that's been conditioned that
and even if people who are are are quite
overweight
uh or you know clearly have consumed a
lot of protein in their life but
they still are afraid that they just
need more of it
and and that more is better but uh i'm
convinced that that
more isn't better and it can have
adverse implications on health
but also i think one thing that people
are totally missing here
and i don't know if you've you talked
about this i'm sure with other with
other guests but
what happens when you emphasize protein
intake
to me you completely overlook the more
nutrient-rich
complex carbohydrates that provide more
fiber
vitamins minerals antioxidants nitric
oxide
water and all these other things to
optimize health or optimize performance
but we're focused on an isolated
nutrient that we often take in isolated
form
and we miss out on all this other stuff
because we're filling up on calories
that could have been
complex carbohydrates which by the way
are you know i have a lot of protein in
them too
the way i think about it and and let me
know how this lands for you guys
is you're correct robert like we've been
sold this narrative that if you don't
drink a protein shake within 10 minutes
of waking up in the morning
that somehow you're not going to be able
to breathe air in and out of your lungs
that we're all walking around
you know basically in this constant
state of protein
deprivation but i don't know about you i
don't know anyone who's gone to the
hospital for a protein deficiency
i just don't think it's a thing i think
you're right matt that almost everybody
is
is far exceeding their daily recommended
uh intake of protein but for some reason
we've been spun this yarn that we need
copious amounts of protein to just
live and i think it's a fallacy in truth
when you look at
food and in specific and specifically
plant-based foods when we're talking
about protein we're talking about amino
acids right
and we're really talking about the nine
essential amino acids that
um that our bodies can't synthesize on
their own and that we
need to get from our food those amino
acids are the building blocks of protein
but in truth if you're grazing randomly
on plant-based foods
it's almost like we've evolved
like and and the plant kingdom has
evolved to just automatically meet those
needs like you're going to meet your 10
percent
of right calories from protein just by
eating plants of you know a relatively
uh you know relative spectrum of plants
throughout the day
and your body takes care of the rest
like it's just not a thing so when you
look at
that that um that number what is it
point
eight grams per kilogram is kind of like
quoted as the main thing like i've
i've calibrated my protein intake
against that
and even when i'm training hard i'm
still like i'm still below that but i'm
improving
i'm not getting injured i'm making gains
and it's often led me to question
you know this whole paradigm altogether
and you know garth davis is probably the
most prominent person he wrote a whole
book protein hall
on this subject matter we spend all this
time
worried about our protein intake
meanwhile we're all fiber deficient
we're all you know micronutrient
deficient
we're you know we're not getting enough
vitamin d or whatever it is we have all
these other gaps
in our diet that should be causing us
concern and yet the focus
always comes back to protein well let's
let's continue a little bit further
that the short answer which i could have
just given you
led with is that if you if you consume
adequate calories based on your body's
needs
you'll get adequate protein you'll get
enough protein that's the thing it's the
calorie intake that's important
so people talk about i gotta build
muscle you know i got to put on mass
well i've i've put on 100 pounds since i
became vegan
120 pounds to 220 pounds and for the
last
decade i haven't consumed protein
powders protein supplements or even had
something i wanted to get into you
because you went you've gone through
this arc in terms of your relationship
with supplements
yeah and with protein i was consuming i
mean i can tell you i was consuming 300
grams of protein 5 000 calories a day
for a while now i consume
less than 100 grams a day how much
you've got sorry to interrupt but how
much of that
previously was in the form of like
protein powders versus
six a day i mean i worked for vega for
10 years i got i had you should have
seen i looked i was like a gnc in my
basement it was unbelievable
i had access to anything i wanted and
and i used it as long as it was
plant-based i was doing really sometimes
five
six protein drinks a day and i actually
i got bigger
and stronger better just overall better
performance the best i've ever been
later in life you know late 30s early
40s on
now a decade without that about any of
those sports supplements
what just vitamin b12 was it just
curiosity or what was the impetus to
ditch that stuff and see what would
happen without it
it came from when i worked in the forks
over knives office and i was downing
vaguely like crazy and brian and robbie
were the only other guys in the office
for
a while and they were teasing me all the
time rabbits got to have this
you know protein drink to tie his shoes
and another supplement to walk across
the room and
you know they just kept on getting on me
like here i was working for this film
about whole foods and reversing disease
and being your best health and all this
stuff
and i was just sitting in the office
drinking powders all day long right but
i get it because you're trying to make
gains
right that's it's one thing forks over
knives is really about
combating chronic lifestyle right it's
not about like killing it in the gym
right but their personal argument
was that you can achieve these things
without the supplementation without the
emphasis on protein
right so that was a relatively untested
high point right and i completely argued
with it i disagreed with it
and so i decided you know i'm going to
enroll in dr campbell's plant-based
nutrition program the
nutrition center for nutrition studies
so i did that
2012. and in that course i was kind of
hilarious
looking back i wrote papers arguing you
know what is
you know what does 80 year old you know
skinny campbell know about building
muscle and being a champion bodybuilder
i argued i wrote papers that if you take
a nfl team
put them on a high protein diet and
another nfl team of equal skill and
talent
put them on a low protein diet the high
protein diet is going to smash the team
then
i said take the you know the skill set
out and just do it weightlifting maybe
just something that's just you know a
really easy thing to measure
the high protein people are going to win
every time and then
and i argued and i argued and then i
decided to do the one thing that so many
people are unwilling to do especially in
my space in the vegan bodybuilding space
was to 100 give it a try cut out all
sport supplements except for vitamin b12
or you know maybe something else that
was necessary vitamin d or
um or dha epa whatever but i really
wasn't doing that it was just b12
and and to cut the emphasis on protein
just stop
just stop thinking about it i mean even
to this day i you know hold the tofu
please you know that's what i really do
not because you were convinced but
because you wanted to test this i had to
test it i had to test it so what
happened
what happened was it just happened to be
the same time that i was getting tired
of bodybuilding
and so i had been i peaked at 195 pounds
at the time and i dropped all the way
down to 165
because i was pursuing running and so
now it's like oh okay
that makes sense is his low protein
diet's not working anymore you know and
i ran a bunch of half marathons with my
wife and i ran
5ks and finished in the top five in
every race that i competed in
i have a background i'm running of
course so it came naturally for me and
it felt good to be back doing it again
we had 165 pounds and then the eve
of the fort collins marathon in colorado
uh this woman recognized me at the gym
and i said hey you're rubber cheek right
it ended up being vanessa espinoza
uh who's now one of my absolute best
friends and i kind of like
you know immediately like puffed up like
a like a rooster because i was so small
and she's like you're one of my heroes
and all this stuff and
i saw her again a week later and again
and we started training together
and in 18 months i went from 165 pounds
to 205 pounds bigger and stronger than
it ever been in my life
while writing shred it and following
this low protein
no supplement except for b12 approach
and it was amazing and that's when i was
convinced that
the nutrients per calorie that you get
from a whole food plant-based diet when
you emphasize especially complex
carbohydrates it's just
doing things like matt said it's doing
things to
help your recovery you're naturally
reducing inflammation you're not eating
pro-inflammatory foods you're eating
anti-inflammatory foods
i could train i was lifting like 120
pound dumbbells in each hand over her
head i'd never done that before
and this was all you actually were
lifting more you were stronger yeah and
bigger and i mean 165 to 205.
and before remember i had maxed out at
195 with five protein drinks a day
four frozen burritos a day seven clif
bars a day doing whatever i could
because it was hard for me to put on
mass and then
this past year with the quarantine and
everything i thought man how cool would
it be
if i could if i could reach that
milestone of putting on a hundred pounds
total
so i started the year at like 208 or so
when i got up to 223 at one point
slimmed down a little bit for this
podcast i was getting
you know my belt wouldn't even work
anymore um but i got pretty i got really
strong
i mean i'm i'm still i'm i'm just using
110 pound dumbbells no spotter needed i
just do my thing and
and that's that's on a low protein
approach and i think people need to put
it to the test
to see for themselves because what
you're missing
by focusing on protein could be all
those benefits of a complex carbohydrate
diet
that help with energy recovery overall
fuel
and performance and i think if people
can give that a try
they're going to see a world of
difference
[Music]
you